good afternoon
everyone my name is dr miller
and the scp we're going to be looking at
today
is scp-966
object class euclid
special containment procedures mtf iota
1
dream hunters and mtf iota 2
air chasers are to be regularly on the
lookout for news about sudden violent
human deaths
related to sleep deprivation in order to
find and neutralize remaining wild
instances
of scp-966 the four specimens of scp-966
three males designated scp-966-1
scp-966-3 and scp-966-4
and one female designated scp-966-2
acquired by the foundation must be
contained in a 10 by 10 meter room made
of steel
lined with lead located on site
two security cameras with infrared
filters and infrared sensitive film are
to be installed inside the room
each specimen of scp-966 is to be fed
with
20 kilograms of meat every month
in the event of scp-966-2 giving birth
the newborn specimen is to be studied
and disposed of before it reaches
maturity
description scp-966
are predatory creatures that resemble
hairless digitalgrade humans
possessing an elongated face with a
mouth lined with needle-like teeth
on each hand they have five claws that
can be up to 20 centimeters long
although sharp these are easily broken
making them
unfit for combat scp-966's height
ranges from 1.4 to 1.6 meters
and they can reach up to 30 kilograms in
weight
physically scp-966 are weak
possessing hollow bones and low muscular
density
they do not seem to rest through sleep
instead
they will suddenly cease all movement at
seemingly random intervals of time
resuming normal activity three to five
minutes later
scp-966 are visible only at wavelengths
ranging from 700 nanometers
to about 900 nanometers this applies to
all of scp-966's tissues
if their skin muscles or organs have
suffered from second to third degree
burns
the affected areas will be visible at
wavelengths ranging from 360 to 900
nanometers
scp-966 feed on medium two large-sized
animals
including humans they hunt either alone
or
in pairs their hunting methods consist
of emitting
a single burst of a previously unknown
type of wave
dub waves in honor of the late doctor
which permanently inhibits the ability
of the affected creature to enter any of
the nerm
and rem sleep stages the ability to
micro sleep is also lost
the effective range of the waves is up
to 20 meters
however tests show that they can be
blocked by post-transition metals
particularly lead all attempts to make
victims of scp-966 sleep
have failed it is still possible to
induce
other forms of unconsciousness although
these will usually prove detrimental to
the affected subject
as they do not provide true rest
after depriving their victims of sleep
scp-966 will stalk their prey
until the lack of rest incapacitates it
at this point scp-966
will proceed to consume it scp-966 have
proven to be very agile and silent
while stalking their victims on occasion
they will deliberately make threatening
noises around the prey
in order to further stress it and may
even physically assault it
if the victim proves to be particularly
durable
other than the common symptoms caused by
sleep deprivation
some victims of scp-966 have shown signs
of suffering from extremely vivid
hallucinations
as well as sudden bouts of rage with no
apparent external stimuli
it is currently thought that these are
the effects of prolonged exposure to
waves why scp-962 continually exposes
these waves to only some of their
victims
is unknown one hypothesis is that
scp-966
will only do this when starving since it
further degenerates the physical and
mental state of their prey
incapacitating it at a faster rate
wild instances of scp-966 are found
all over the world since their discovery
in nineteen
the foundation has succeeded in greatly
thinning their numbers
though they are still found in large
quantities in many countries
particularly and
just gonna i'm just gonna turn the
monitor off
here don't really want to look at that
face
anyway i think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
albino neko james saba andre
beschert jax merrick
pablo ice 917 burlington the cat
all the time gaming justin day
researcher boulevare pierce m hamlin
curie coma white crew
nicholas james vojak bryson bailey
my archive curator nick cody tench
the android slump god
quartz 563 and tree hero
thank you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash
the vulgan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you